prochaine bonjour merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france en direct de
téhéran où vous vivez alors dans quel
état d'esprit se trouve ce matin les
iraniens et à votre avis seront ils
nombreux à se rendre aux urnes
bonjour daou tout d'abord merci de
m'avoir invité et je tiens juste à
préciser que je suis athée rend
actuellement mais j'habite à paris
alors l'état d'esprit c'est que les
iraniens j'allais vous dire ne se
préoccupent pas tellement des éditions
les les réformateurs les libéraux la
majorité d'entre eux ne vont pas aller
voter
ceux qui ceux qui vont aller voter ce
sera les ultraconservateurs c'est eux
qui sont motivés pour aller voter pour
élire monsieur ebrahim raïssi qui est le
chef qui le juge en chef du pouvoir
judiciaire qui est le fils spirituel
comme vous avez dit de l'ayatollah ali
kameni et qui sera probablement élue je
me trouvais hier soir et avant-hier soir
pour ceux qui connaissent qui était un
peu à taji c'est le bazar qui est dans
le nord de téhéran qui est dans le
quartiers très aisés et même dans ce
quartier là il n'y avait que des
supporters de ebrahim raïssi qui étaient
là qui montraient leur soutien et les
affiches qu'on voit c'est que des
affiches du du juge en chef monsieur
ebrahim raïssi justement quels sont les
enjeux de cette élection dont le
résultat semble être connues d'avancé
alors les enjeux pour les iraniens aussi
bien pour la classe aisée que la classe
défavorisée
c'est l'emploi et le pouvoir d'achat le
les prix augmentent
ici en iran tous les jours l'inflation
est de 40% même les prix dans de la
nourriture augmente pratiquement tous
les jours tous les jours les gens ne
peuvent plus manger pratiquement faire
les classes défavorisées de viande de
poulet parce que les prix sont
exorbitants
les prix de l'immobilier augmentent tous
les jours les loyers augmentent ou les
gens donc ce que ce qui préoccupe avant
tout les iraniens c'est tout d'abord le
pouvoir d'achat et d'emploi
et comme les iraniens sont un peuple
fier et nationaliste évidemment il ya
cette question du nucléaire qui est là
et qu'ils se disent pourquoi nous
iranien on n'aurait pas droit à
nucléaire civil alors qu'on a un peuple
on a les compétences civiles et
scientifique et technique pour pouvoir
accéder aux pour aaa au nucléaire
civile alors l'arrivée justement de là
ici peut-être au pouvoir vous l'avez dit
il est sur la même ligne que le guide
suprême il a également le soutien des
gardiens de la révolution un parlement
qui est acquis ça veut dire quoi plus de
cohérence dans les positions iraniennes
plus de stabilité
ça veut dire oui tout simplement que les
iraniens comme l'a dit même le guide
suprême avant ils veulent négocier
ils veulent que les américains rejoints
de l'accord l'accord sur le nucléaire et
que l'iran bon déjeuner jamais sortie de
l'accord sur le nucléaire mais
commencent à augmenter la production
aujourd'hui enfin aujourd'hui ou demain
une fois que raïssi sera à sera et vu le
parlement le guide suprême sont à beira
ici et histoire une position beaucoup
plus favorable pour négocier avec les
américains que les rois ni et puisque
quand on a nivelé négocier tous les
conservateurs lui mettait des bâtons
dans les roues
aujourd'hui il a les mains libres et on
sait que derrière le rideau il ya des
pourparlers et que anne accord sera
bientôt sera trouvée et ce sera ce sera
la victoire une victoire de plus pour
monsieur raïssi qui viendra devant le
peuple iranien dire qu'il a réussi à
négocier un nouvel accord sur le
nucléaire et que le pays sera libéré et
que les sanctions seront levées
justement on sait que la levée des
sanctions économiques américaines semble
être un des moyens pour l'iran de faire
repartir son économie vous parliez
justement de cette crise que sont en
train de vivre les les iraniens avec
l'arrivée des conservateurs au pouvoir
qu'elle pourrait être l'issue des
discussions en cours à vienne sur
l'accord nucléaire vous êtes plutôt
optimiste je suis vraiment enfin
beaucoup plus optimiste qu'avant comme
je vous ai dit les sans droits ni
n'avait pas beaucoup de marge de
manoeuvre
alors que monsieur raïssi aura pourra
faire ce qu'il veut et il pourra
négocier évidemment il va pas négocier
sur les armes qu'on dit et balistiques
mais il va pouvoir négocier avec une
position fort avec un parlement qui lui
est acquis et commencer c'est le guide
suprême qui qui montre dans un cadre
légal
les les dote pour tout ce qui est des
affaires étrangères s'est lui guide
suprême et raïssi suisse ce que dit le
suprême et il va signer un accord et
c'est accor va libérer normalement de
l'iran est-ce qu'on se conter cet accord
sera signé on sait pas la seule question
qui est important c est ce que raïs y
est les iraniens pourront faire
confiance à la parole américaine puisque
dans quatre ans il y aura un nouveau
président et si c'est un président
républicain il pourra ressortir de là
donc c'est la seule question qui
suspendu
dernière question concernant le pétrole
iranien on sait qu'il est essentiel
économiquement mais aussi politiquement
au payer les conservateurs est ce que il
pourrait justement se prévaloir d'être
ceux qui ont relancé le pays là où les
modérés ont échoué c'est exactement ce
qu'ils sont en train de faire ils sont 1
2 ghz ont mis les bâtons dans les roues
de roanne et une fois que l'accord sera
signé
les sanctions sur le pétrole et sur les
devises étrangères et enfin les sur les
banques seront enlevés ils pourront dire
que voilà nous on a réussi là où les
réformateurs ont échoué et que vous
peuple iranien je vous devez rester
conservateurs vous devez voter pour nos
conservateurs parce qu'on vient de lever
les sanctions
le pétrole on commença ont réussi à le
vendre de nouveaux il y aura de l'entrée
des devises il y aura beaucoup d'argent
qui vont rentrer dans l'iran est ce que
ça va être investi pour le peuple
iranien ou pas on sait pas mais c'est
une victoire pour lui pourra dire voilà
moi j'ai réussi là où les réformateurs
ont échoué et on pourra aller de nouveau
et on pourra se on pourra être très fort
face aux américains est ce que c'est
vrai ou pas vrai on sait pas merci
beaucoup en tout cas cours au cham nous
d'avoir répondu à nos questions en
direct de téhéran je rappelle que vous
êtes avocat franco iranien